♪
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
HOORAY!
YES, HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
IT'S BEEN A GREAT WEEK SO FAR.
KAT'S STILL ON HER HONEYMOON.
YEAH, I THINK WE HAVE TAPE.
[SNORING]
>> Greg: AT LEAST WE KNOW
THEY'RE STILL ALIVE.
BUT EVEN THOUGH KAT'S NOT BACK,
LOOK WHO IS.
YES, ANOTHER BLOND PSYCHOPATH.
OH, SHE'S NOT THAT BAD.
OKAY, SHE IS YOU KNOW, I BET SHE
WAS THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS THE SECRETARY
OF STATE.
I SPENT, YOU KNOW, MANY DAYS ON
AIRPLANES FLYING FROM PLACE TO
PLACE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO HAVE
A REAL DEMOCRACY AND ONE OF THE
HALL MARKS OF A I REAL DEMOCRACY
IS THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER.
>> Greg: YEAH.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS A
HALLMARK OF DEMOCRACY?
A FREE AND FAIR ELECTION AND THE
RIGHT TO PITCH ABOUT IT IF YOU
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS JUST THAT.
YOU KNOW, KIND OF LIKE YOU DID,
YOU OLD GAS BAG IN SENSIBLE
SHOES.
AND HILLARY, YOU REMEMBER
LIBYA'S PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER RIGHT?
IT ENDED UP WITH TWO CIVIL WARS
MURDERED AMERICANS AND YOU
SAYING, WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT
MAKE.
ANYWAY APPARENTLY SHE WAS A
GUEST ON THE VIEW, WHICH IS LIKE
SPRINKLING SAW DUST ON VOMIT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS REALLY, IF THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
IT COULD BE.
BUT I WONDER IF SHE WOULD NOT BE
HONEST IF SHE DIDN'T SAY THERE
WAS A SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> I WOULD NOT BE HONEST IF I
DIDN'T SAY I THINK THERE WAS A
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND THAT'S A CRIME.
>> LED BY DONALD TRUMP.
>> LED BY DONALD TRUMP,
ENCOURAGED BY DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: YEAH.
YOU KNOW, SHE HAD A POINT WHEN
SHE SAID I WOULD NOT BE HONEST.
BUT IT'S REALLY JUST COLLECTIVE
AMNESIA AND EVERYONE'S PLAYING
ALONG.
EXCEPT FOR OUR VERY OWN DUMB SON
OF A BITCH PETER DOOCY.
TAKE IT AWAY, PETER.
>> YOU TWEETED, IN 2016.
>> I KNEW THIS WAS COMING.
I WAS WAITING PETER WHEN YOU
WERE GOING TO ASK ME THAT
QUESTION.
>> Greg: SHE WAS WAITING FOR IT
YET WAS STILL SHOCKINGLY
UNPREPARED FOR IT.
POOR KJP SHE CHECKED EVERY BOX
FOR THE JOB EXCEPT COMPETENCE.
AT LEAST PETER ASKED THE
QUESTION NO ONE ELSE IN THE
MEDIA DARED TO ASK SINCE IT WAS
THEIR ANTI TRUMP NARRATIVES.
IT'S ABOUT MOTIVATING THE BASE
TO VOTE THROUGH FEAR.
THAT'S WHY THE BIDEN SPEECH LAST
WEEK WAS SO DARK AND ANGRY.
IN CASE YOU FORGOT, HERE'S A
CLIP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I'M SORRY, THAT WAS
HUNTER BIDEN GETTING THE RESULTS
OF HIS LATEST STD TEST.
ANYWAY.
SO REPEAT AFTER ME, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE EXTREME, TRUMP
IS A FASCIST, PARENTS ARE
TERRORISTS, AND I'M TOO HANDSOME
FOR TV.
ALL LIES, EXCEPT FOR THAT ONE.
SO HOW DO YOU FIGHT FAKE FEAR?
WELL, YOU DO SO WITH REAL FEAR.
FACT IS, THE REAL PROBLEMS
FACING AMERICANS ARE SCARIER
THAN HILLARY IN A TWO PIECE
EATING A THREE PIECE.
GOT SKY HIGH CRIME PERSISTENT
INFLATION, A SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT
PREFERS INDOCTRINATION OVER
EDUCATION WITH DRAG SHOWS ON
DEMAND AT YOUR LOCAL MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
IT'S ALL BROUGHT TO YOU BY LEFT
WING POLICIES.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GIN UP FEAR
PEOPLE GETTING PUSHED IN FRONT
OF SUB WAYS IS STRONGER THAN ANY
HYPERBOLE WHICH IS WHY THE MEDIA
AND DEMS NEED TO PUSH FAKE
MISERY, FAKE FEAR TO DROWN OUT
THE REAL.
>> TWO OF THE HALL MARKS OF A
FASCIST POLITICAL PARTY ARE ONE,
THEY DON'T ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
ELECTIONS THAT DON'T GO THEIR
WAY AND TWO THEY EMBRACE
POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
RIGHT TO SOUND THE ALARM THIS
WEEK ABOUT THESE CONTINUING
ATTACKS ON OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
ORDER FROM THE OUTSIDE BY DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS MOVEMENT.
>> IF YOU LOOK UP FASCISM IN THE
DICTIONARY, YOU GONE FIND ALL OF
THOSE THINGS SO I'M REALLY NOT
SURE WHAT THE REPUBLICANS ARE
ALL UPSET ABOUT OTHER THAN THE
FACT THAT IT WAS NAMED.
>> Greg: I LOVE HOW SHE PRE
TENDS TO USE A DICTIONARY.
NOW DON'T LET ALL THIS FASCIST
TALK GET TO YOU.
LIKE MY PROCTOLOGIST TOLD ME AT
MY LAST VISIT, KEEP YOUR POWDER
DRY.
IT'S JUST A SIGN OF DESPERATION.
IT'S A SIGN OF DESPERATION BY
DESPERATE PUSHABILITY YOU KNOW,
LIKE WHEN BRIAN KILMEADE STANDS
UNDER THE MISTLETOE.
THEIR IDEAS FAIL, THEIR POLICIES
REWARD THE BAD AND PUNISH THE
GOOD.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO SELL EXCEPT
FEAR THAT THE ALTERNATIVE'S EVEN
WORSE THAN THEY ARE.
THAT SHOULD BE THE LINE THAT
JOE'S REMEMBERED FOR WHEN
HISTORIANS LOOK BACK.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO SELL BUT FEAR
ITSELF.
HE'S PLAGIARIZED EVERYBODY ELSE
WHY NOT FDR.
BUT IT HAS TO SUCCEED TO BE A
DEMOCRAT VOTER.
YOUR ADDRESS IS A VACANT LOT AND
THE ONLY WAY TO GET YOU TO CARE
ABOUT SOMETHING IS TO MAKE YOU
FEEL AWFUL.
IT'S LIKE HOW PANHANDLERS USE
UNDERFED DOGS, OH, YOUR POOR
PUPPY, HERE'S SOME MONEY FOR
HEROINE.
SO WHAT ABOUT VOTERS WHO ARE ON
THE FENCE?
THEY LOOK AT TWO COMPETING FEARS
WHICH ONE IS MORE MOTIVATING?
HOW CAN A VOTER BE WHEN THEY'RE
SO FAR APART.
THAT'S LIKE STRADDLING THE GRAND
CANYON, THAT'S LIKE SAYING I
CAN'T DECIDE WHICH TICKETS TO
BUY ONE FOR MAUI THE OTHER FOR
MAROON5.
AND A GUY TRYING TO SURPRISE HIS
WIFE ON THEIR ANNIVERSARY IS IT
A DIAMOND RING OR TWO TICKETS TO
WRESTLE MANIA.
BUT ONE FEAR IS OBVIOUSLY -- I
SHOULD HAVE READ THE ROOM.
BUT ONE FEAR IS OBVIOUSLY
PHONEY, THE LEFT ACCUSING
EVERYONE ELSE OF BEING FASCIST
WHO ARE PUSHING FOR CIVIL WAR.
IT'S A EXCLAIM EASILY DESTROYED
EVERY TIME YOU WALK OUTSIDE AND
SEE PEOPLE GETTING ALONG
TOGETHER.
IT'S RIDICULOUS HOW LITTLE OUR
POLITICS MATTER IN EVERYDAY LIFE
BECAUSE WE HAVE LIVES.
WHICH IS WHY THE RIGHT SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT REAL-WORLD FEARS
CREATED BY DEMOCRAT POLICIES.
NO CASH BAIL, REDUCED
SENTENCING, TURNING GRAND
LARCENY INTO A LESSER OUTRAGE
THAN LITTERING.
THOSE ARE REAL CONCERNS.
BUT WHO'S THE BEST AT PUSHING
IT?
WELL, THE DEMS ARE LUCKY, THEY
CAN PUSH THEIR FEARS AND THE
MEDIA'S ON BOARD.
BUT YOU TALK ABOUT REAL STUFF,
LIKE CRIME, IMMIGRATION,
INFLATION, THE MEDIA CALLS YOU
FASCIST FOR DARING TO SUGGEST
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS TO THESE
SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
BUT THAT'S FINE.
FOCUS ON REALITY AND LET THEM
LIVE IN THEIR FANTASY LAND AND
MAYBE IT'S NOT A BAD THING THAT
THEY THINK YOU'RE A FASCIST.
IT WILL KEEP THEM FROM BORROWING
YOUR LAWN MOWER.
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE HAS TWO MORE AWARDS FOR
WOMEN IN JOURNALISM THAN I DO.
ANCHOR OF THE STORY MARTHA
MacCALLUM.
HE'S MR. CLEAN ON THE OUTSIDE
AND PERRY MASON ON THE OUTSIDE,
FORMER ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
MATT WHITAKER.
SHE'S THE ONLY LAWYER THAT
COMMUTES BY CARTWHEEL,
OUTNUMBERED COHOST EMILY
COMPAGNO!
AND IT'S A GOOD THING THAT HE
DOESN'T SUFFER FROM ALTITUDE
SICKNESS.
MY MASTER SIDE KICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS!
>> Greg: MARTHA, HOW DO YOU TAKE
BIDEN'S KIND OF LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW, KIND OF AGENDA OF FEAR?
I THINK IT HAPPENS TO BE
SOMEWHAT EFFECTIVE BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT BUT DO YOU
THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK?
>> Matt: AS I SAY IT'S LEANING
INTO IT.
HE FEELS LIKE IT WORKS.
I WAS STRUCK BY THAT VIDEO AGAIN
OF HIM WITH THE RED BACKGROUND.
YOU COULDN'T SEE THE MARINES ON
EARTH OH SIDE OF HIM AS HE WAS
DOING THAT.
IT'S VERY STRANGE.
HE'S VERY PAIL IN THAT VIDEO, A
VERY, VERY ORDER IMAGE AND I
THINK YOU MAKE A GRAIN POINT
ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT WHICH IS THE HORRIFIC
SCENES OF CRIME.
YOU CAN THROW A STICK OUT AND
FIND A MILLION VIDEOS OF
HORRIFIC THINGS HAPPENING TO
PEOPLE, PEOPLE BEING COLD COCKED
IN THE SUBWAY AND HITTING THEIR
HEAD AND ENDING UP IN THE
HOSPITAL.
ALL KINDS OF -- THE THING THAT
REALLY STRIKES ME IS THE IMAGES
OF PEOPLE GETTING OFF THE BUSES
IN NEW YORK CITY AND HAVING
THEIR HANDS SHAKEN AND I KEEP
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW, YOU
SHOWED LAST NIGHT MARK HIS
RACKET AT THE U.S. OPEN AND POOR
NOVAK JOKE VEHICLE CAN'T GET
INTO THE COUNTRY.
MEANWHILE EVERYBODY'S HANDS
GETTING SHAKEN BROUGHT INTO THE
CITY WHO KNOWS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE HAD A VACCINE.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GREAT POINT I
DIDN'T THINK OF THAT MAINLY
BECAUSE I NEVER WATCH TENNIS.
>> Matt: YOU'RE MISSING OUT.
>> Greg: I HAD NO IDEA THAT THEY
ACTUALLY TELL VIE IT.
>> Matt: I'M SORRY?
>> Greg: NO, I UNDERSTAND PICKLE
BALL COMPLETELY, BUT TENNIS --
>> Martha: OH MY GOD NO ONE
UNDERSTAND THAT COMPLETELY.
>> Greg: TENNIS IS A RIP OFF OF
PICKLE BALL
>> Martha: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: RIGHT?
>> Martha: RIGHT ON GREG.
>> Greg: TENNIS A POOR MAN'S
PICKLE BALL.
I COINED THAT PHRASE.
MATT, YOU LOOK LIKE A FASCIST.
RIGHT?
>> Matt: NO.
>> Greg: HE'S LIKE A FASCIST
TEDDY BEAR.
>> Tyrus: THAT'S NOT BETTER.
>> Greg: HE OFFERED ME A HUG
BEFORE WALKING IN HERE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT -- THERE'S
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO PROBABLY
THINK THAT YOU'RE A FISHEST
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN AND --.
>> Matt: BECAUSE I STOOD FOR THE
RULE OF LAW.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Matt: BECAUSE I DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE RIGHT REASON?
BECAUSE I WANT LESS CRIME?
BECAUSE I WORRIED ABOUT WEARING
THIS WATCH IN NEW YORK CITY
TODAY FOR FEAR OF MOTORCYCLES
RUNNING UP AND RIPPING IT OFF MY
ARM?
YEAH.
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
SOMEBODY TRY AND MUG YOU,
THOUGH.
THAT WOULD BE FUNNY.
>> Matt: BUT IT'S SERIOUS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Matt: COMING TO NEW YORK CITY
IS THRILLING BUT FOR THE WRONG
REASON.
BECAUSE YOU GET THE TINGLE THAT
MAYBE, YOU KNOW, HASN'T HAPPENED
SINCE BARACK OBAMA WAS ELECTED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S A FEAR
TINGLE.
>> Greg: I GET THAT A LOT AFTER
I -- WELL, ANYWAY...
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I THINK WE'VE ALL HAD
THE FEAR TINGLE.
>> Matt: BUT DID YOU SEE HILLARY
CLINTON IN THAT SAME INTERVIEW,
IT'S A FRIENDLY MEDIA.
SHE NEVER COMES TO THE DIFFICULT
QUESTION LIKE MARTHA WOULD DO
AND SO SHE WAS ABLE TO SAY OH,
JIM COMEY SAID I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AFTER THE
FACT.
LIKE NO HE DIDN'T.
SHE JUST MADE THIS STORY UP.
NOW SHE SAID IT NOBODY'S
CHALLENGED IT SO IT'S
THROUGHOUT.
>> Greg: I TRIED TO LOOK FOR
THAT SO I ASSUMED SHE SAID IT SO
IT HAPPENED.
BUT IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S CRAZY.
SEE EMILY.
WOW, YOU'RE TAN.
>> Emily: YEAH.
>> Greg: WHERE WERE YOU?
>> Emily: GREECE AND THEN THE
JERSEY SHORE.
BOTH OF THEM PAIR DIES.
>> Greg: FANTASTIC.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
HILLARY OR FEAR?
>> Emily: WELL, BOTH.
BECAUSE YOU JUST HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD WHEN YOU SAID, OH, I
ASSUMED IT WAS TRUE WHEN I HEARD
HER SAY THAT AND THE BIGGEST
THING THAT STRIKES ME, IN
ADDITION TO THE BLATANT
HYPOCRISY FROM THE LEFT IS THE
SHEAR GAS LIGHTING THAT KEEPS
COMING OUT OF MOUTH PIECES OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO HILLARY IT'S OKAY FOR HER TO
HAVE CLASSIFIED E-MAILS ON HER
SERVER BUT GOD FORBID FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SOMETHING OF
THE LIKE IN HIS SITUATION
THEY'RE CURRENTLY UNDERGOING.
YOU KNOW, GOD FOR BID IF KARIN
JEANNE-PIERRE SAYS I KNEW YOU
WOULD SAY THAT, SHE KNOWS PETER
DOOCY WOULD BRING UP HER CLAIMS
OF STOLEN ELECTIONS IN PUT
APPROXIMATELY INSTANCES THEN WHY
WASN'T SHE PREPARED OR
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SEVERITY OF IT.
BUT IT'S NOT OKAY FOR OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE GOP.
IT'S OKAY FOR KATHY GRIFFEN TO
CALL FOR CIVIL WAR IF
REPUBLICANS ARE VOTED INTO
OFFICE, FOR MAXINE WATERS TO
CALL FOR VIOLENCE.
BUT WHEN A GOP DOES THEY'RE
FASCIST AND IT SHOULD BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
THEY'RE BRUSHING OFF THE
STATISTICS AND HORRIBLE THINGS
HAPPENING IN CITIES AND BAIL
REFORM LEADING TO PEOPLE BEING
HURT AND FAMILIES SUFFERING
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SUIT THEIR
AGENDA BUT THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP
GAS LIGHTING UNTIL WE VOTE
EVERYONE OUT IN NOVEMBER, WHICH
IS COMING.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I'M ALWAYS TOUCHED WHEN
THEY APPLAUD MY QUESTIONS.
>> Tyrus: YOU DIDN'T EVEN ASK IT
YET.
THAT'S GOOD.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
BUT THE ANTICIPATION, THEY OFTEN
HAVE TO CONTROL THEIR NERVES BY
CLAPPING.
>> Tyrus: YES.
IT'S A RARE SKILL.
>> Greg: YES.
TYRUS, WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
WE'RE SEEING THIS IMAGINED WAR
AND THEN LIKE REAL STRUGGLES.
WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE THE
REPUBLICANS?
IT'S SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE NOT
PICKING UP ON THIS.
>> Tyrus: MY ADVICE WOULD BE
JUST KIND OF SIT THERE, GO
UH-HUH.  UH-HUH.
BECAUSE THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY,
SCHIFF'S WRITING THIS SCREEN
PLAY AND IT'S NOT GOING TO GET
PICKED UP.
THEY CONTINUE TO LIVE IN FAKE
FEAR WORLD AND IT'S ALMOST
ENTERTAINING, THE FACT THAT HE
WOULD GO TO THAT MUCH TROUBLE.
THERE WAS A TEAM TO PUT THAT
TOGETHER, YOU KNOW, APPARENTLY
THEY HAD TO WATCH A STAR WARS
MARATHON THE NIGHT BEFORE, YOU
KNOW, AND THE ONLY THING HE
DIDN'T SAY WAS LIKE THE WIND
MILLS WILL BE FULLY OPERATIONAL.
YOU KNOW, THEY JUST TRY, THEY
LIVE IN THAT EXTERIOR WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT AND THEY STAY THERE
BECAUSE YOU CAN PICK AND PULL,
AND IF YOU CALL THEM ON IT THEY
JUST CHANGE IT.
WHY WASN'T SHE PREPARED?
IN THE FIRST WORLD YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE PREPARED.
ANYTIME YOU GET ASKED A QUESTION
YOU ANSWER WITH ANOTHER
QUESTION.
THAT DRIVES US CRAZY.
WHAT WE NEED TO STAY FOCUSED ON
IS VOTING THEM OUT BECAUSE LET'S
BE FAIR, IF THEY WANTED A CIVIL
WAR, I THINK THE REPUBLICANS ARE
THE WRONG ONES TO CALL IT ON.
FOR ONE, WE'RE NOT GOING TO BURN
DOWN OUR OWN CITY FIRST.
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: UH-HUH.
>> Tyrus: YOU KNOW?
AND BY THE TIME YOU FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WORK THE LITTLE GUNS YOU
WERE TRYING TO GET RID OF
>> Greg: FAIR POINT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tyrus: I STRONGLY SUGGEST YOU
RETHINK THAT.
>> Greg: YES, IT'S NOT A GOOD
PLAN.
>> Tyrus: SHE'S A COMEDIAN MAYBE
IT WAS JUST A REALLY GOOD JOKE.
I WAS JOKING.
>> Greg: YES, EXACTLY.
AT LEAST SHE'S BACK IN THE NEWS,
GOOD FOR HER I SAY.
COME ON THE SHOW KATHY WE'LL